now I'm going to be pre-testing
Churchill's Scottish back sword
so I'll just find my way
[Music]
Billy Robert congratulations you've made
it to the final round of this
competition
now we're sending you back to your home
forges to recreate an iconic weapon that
helped win World War II
the Scottish back sword
known for assaulting axis positions with
his Scottish back sword drawn Mad Jack
Churchill earned his name and the
respect of his troops for his famed
exploits during World War II the back
sword first came of fashion during the
16th century and is recognized for its
basket Hilt that covers the user's hand
offering complete protection
featuring a straight and lethal single
edge the weapon was a brutal slicer and
Thruster on the battlefield especially
when wielded by Mad Jack a true wartime
hero Mad Jack eventually served as a
Commando leader helping the Allied
Forces save Europe from destruction
the Scottish back sword is actually a
very unique weapon because of that big
guard basket Hill that it has over there
when you pick it up you realize wow this
is on a straight on attack you're not
able to really extend your wrist this
way for extension for thrusting and
everything else it's got to be at an
angle because there's way to that I'll
just find my way
if you're not a user sometimes you
create the hilt just to protect it but
you don't understand what's happening on
the inside when you're moving the wrist
when you're moving the hand inside there
it shouldn't be hitting anything it
shouldn't be an issue at all and the
weight distribution of that should not
put a lot of stress on your wrist the
basket tilt alone dictates how your
wrist will move in there or can't move
in there
four
five
what I loved about that Broad Sword was
that I was looking at the basket it
protects my hand it protects me but at
the same time I'm in the feeling that
hey my best defense is an offense so to
me that's a piece of metal that's
surrounding my head I gotta punch with
it it's an iron boxing glove
foreign
test we do have a set plan but sometimes
it changes sometimes the weapon performs
better and we're expecting okay you
should get this down in five strikes
after two it's like done
I will not be denied
all right bladesmiths Captain Mad Jack
Churchill may have been mad enough to
take a back sword into Modern Combat but
what I want to know is are your swords
mad enough if called upon to kill
to that end I will deliver some killing
blows to this ballistics dummy
did it here first you ready for this I
came here to watch you kill and chew
bubble gum and I'm out of bubble gum all
right let's do this
oh my God
[Music]
all right Billy first stop I really like
the way that the Damascus pattern shows
in your sword
now your handle it's comfortable there
are no hot spots every cut you do with
this blade is sharp enough to cut deeply
overall your weapon will kill
thank you very much
all right Robert your turn sir are you
ready I'm ready let's do this
[Music]
foreign
Roberts talk about your back sword here
the tip very pointy thrust and easily
cuts on the way out
your handle here needs loose it's really
wiggling in my hand but overall sir your
back sword
will kill thank you
blade Smith's welcome to the strength
test today I'm going to take your swords
and I'm going to clear a path through
this big block of ice and I don't really
care what your swords do to the ice I
want to see what the ice does to your
swords Billy you look ready to be first
Jay I was born ready
[Music]
nice job thank you I'm sure you could
see when I was striking that the blade
flexed all over the place and came right
back to where it was in the beginning
everything's tight
nice job thank you very much Robert how
you feeling I'm ready good I'm ready to
oh no
I really don't know what to think right
now
it's right here is where it hurts feels
like something pulled watching Jay
scream out in pain like that I feel that
pain as well it's kind of catching me a
little bit back here
I hate that something that I did caused
pain to another person plus it's loose
I see Jay stepping off the testing floor
I'm pretty sure this is this is a this
is it for me
blade Smith sent any one of our finale
competitions the way that you design
those blades to perform in our
challenges is always taken into
consideration and Robert unfortunately
your weapon has hurt our user so
severely that we had to send them to the
emergency room
your weapon has been given a vote of no
confidence and cannot move forward in
testing and for that reason I have to
ask you to please leave the forge
first and foremost I hope that Jay
doesn't suffer any long-term effects of
this injury
I took my time making sure that
everything was safe on this blade so to
find out that I missed something it's
kind of devastating you know
Billy your blade is sharp deadly and
strong and you are the Voyager fire
champion and that is a title that comes
with a check for ten thousand dollars
good job brother
whoa I'm the forged in fire champion
this is awesome
definitely not the way that I hope to
win but I was given the privilege of
doing this for a day when I can also
honor those who have given me the
freedom to do this this has been an
amazing experience and I'm very blessed
and honored to have been a part of